[Music]
hey do you play pokemon go do you have a
map cuz I just got lost in your eyes no
it's on the menu me and you
[Music]
little band-aid
because I just feel for you my best
pick-up line is walking up to a guy kind
of like filling his shirt a little bit
like do you know your shirts made out of
he's like what boyfriend material roses
are red violets are green
I like your legs and what's in between
would you like a drink I just dare at
them into it that's my big up line I
don't know I don't have any pickup lines
really well it's my pickup line on you
what are you gonna take me on an
adventure that's what she said it works
obviously I was in San Diego and of
English so are usually from San Diego or
Jasmine's House of Pain how can I hurt
you these would be a dominatrix so that
kind of worked I am an old lady but
years and years ago like 45 years ago I
met my husband by walking by I'm
repeatedly while he was talking to my
best friend Wendy and said hey hey
finally he looked
haven't I seen you on this trail before
what's your signed astrological sign
that goes way back when we were married
like two years and he's best pickup line
was if I wanted to hear some music on
the bus and then we got married
releasing some music and I met my wife
just to give a ride on my motorcycle and
that's all that took sometimes their
inner Etta's a sugar packet drop it pick
it up and say you forgot your business
card hey baby I wish you were a DNA
helicase that you could unzipper my
genes I usually walk into the woman and
I say excuse me
how old you oh wait I'm not supposed to
ask that how much do you weigh you'd be
surprised how many women laugh at that I
used to stand on carnet Avenue and ask
girls hey do you know where Garnett
Avenue is how about what you're doing or
what's up
nobody uses pickup lines anymore so what
do you do that you just talk to him make
him laugh
that's it back then if you play dumb you
got a lot more but my pickup line got me
this so what else can I say hey you're
looking good back then we had mood rings
I think they still have mood rings but
when I was getting to know my future
wife I had her put a mood ring on and it
turned completely black which means she
was strained and anxious so
and then it was seven days after that
that we were engaged and three four
months later married could definitely
work it was like he he said he tried
this on for me and it turned black and
he said I gotta find out more
it's trained in aegis what strange and
anxious is all about I've asked me out
[Music]